Hello
everybody!
Hello, we're gonna start off by... whoa Batman!
Okay this like pan up all the way.
Yeah let's just end it off on his pecs I guess.
Damn!
No face!
We're not here to look at Batman's face!
We know his real assets right there!
Whoa Batman!
Damn!
Oh my god!
Hello everybody!
Uh... yeah!
Surprise!
A Batman stream!
I just... you know... his eyes are... yeah his eyes are up here!
Yes!
If the game knows where it's supposed to end...
Then...
All I'm trying to do is like, you know, I'm trying to...
Whoa!
See, look at that!
Why is it never showing me his face?
But... yeah.
Anyway, as I was saying...
Surprise stream.
I really wanted to play Batman!
Yeah, like, I just... I just really wanted to play Batman.
We weren't able to earlier, so I was like...
Ah!
I don't want to be like, you know...
The only gaming streams we had was literally Apex.
I was like, I don't really want to have like...
Back-to-back Apex.
So, um...
Surprise... double stream.
We're gonna start off with Batman.
And then later on, transition over to Apex.
Cause I just thought it was... I don't know.
I thought it was a little weird...
To have like, back-to-back Apex.
For... I know like... I know you're like...
But Doki, it's all... you're all about Apex.
Guys, it's not just... I'm more...
I'm more than just Apex.
Oh my god, Sam!
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
Guys, just like Batman...
I'm more than just Apex.
Just like Batman!
There's more to me than just Pax, guys!
There's more to me than just Apex.
There's more!
And that is why we're playing Batman.
I'm a variety streamer.
Exactly.
Anyway, I've never played...
I've never played Batman before.
I've never played...
Okay, I've never played this type of Batman game before.
I've actually...
I remember the...
I remember my dad playing the Batman Arkham Asylum...
Like the Batman series from the Arkham Asylum series.
A long time ago.
Did you guys know this game is 10 years old?
Yes, I...
I know a lot of dragoons are gonna be incredibly old.
Feel very old right now.
But this game is like more than 14 years old now.
It is almost 14 years...
Oh no, it's not even almost.
It is 14 years old now.
And...
But yes, I remember 14 years ago...
I watched my dad play this game.
And I don't really remember much.
I know it's like voiced by Mark Hamill and Kevin Conroy.
Who are like... sort of like the OG voice actors.
And like the voice actors for like Batman.
So it's gonna be very very exciting.
I've always loved DC comics.
And I've always loved DC characters.
I've always loved like...
Well, I don't really like Batman per se.
I like Joker as a character.
I think Batman...
I was just not like...
Like you know...
He's just Batman.
But honestly...
I liked Joker more than Batman.
Because I felt like Joker was much more of an interesting character.
Than he is.
He's just you know...
He's like a billionaire...
Depressed man.
Who just...
You know...
Number one rule.
We don't kill anybody.
But!
I'll beat you up so hard.
That you'll have to deal with like millions of dollars of hospital bills.
And at least...
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
His one rule being like...
I can't kill anybody.
But like...
I feel like it's much worse.
Being like ridden with like hospital debt.
Medical debt.
Versus like...
You know...
Like...
Honestly for him.
He doesn't care.
He's a fucking billionaire.
He doesn't have to live through medical debt.
But like medical bills.
But...
But an average criminal...
Dealing with crippling medical debt.
Is a lot worse than just being dead.
And I feel like...
That you know...
You can be like...
Wow Batman.
That's so kind of you.
To not kill them.
But I'm like...
At this point...
They might as well be dead.
Like...
He might as...
He owns the...
Wait!
You're right!
That's so fucked up Batman.
If you...
He owns the hospital?
That's pretty fucked up.
Oh my god.
This goes so deep.
Anyway.
Let's fucking play Batman.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'll say...
Okay.
What is the difficulty?
We'll do norm...
I'm gonna do tough...
Oh my god.
No.
I don't wanna deal with bullet sponges.
There should only be a type I heard.
Expert.
Bro.
Okay.
This is not an FPS.
I can't...
I don't wanna deal with bullet sponges right now.
Um...
This game isn't old.
The Xbox 360.
Oh my god.
I can't believe you're trying to bring up the Xbox right now.
Batman.
Okay.
I'm gonna say it.
A lot of like the DC heroes character wise, they're pretty bland.
Like not just...
Sorry.
Not just DC heroes.
Marvel and DC heroes.
Some of them are incredibly bland when it comes to like personality.
I feel like the villains are much more interesting.
Is this a Batman that uses guns?
There's a lot of them.
Whoa!
I hope the volume's not too loud.
Sound check guy.
Help me.
Mark him.
There he is.
Oh!
I'm joking!
Oh, a little quiet?
On a quiet side?
Oh, don't worry.
As long as the intro comes out...
The intro is over.
Oh my god.
You know, the graphics didn't age quite well for something that was 14 years ago.
I think like, okay, hot take.
I think like a lot of the older games look a lot better than the newer games.
Because they were not pressured to like make games a lot.
Like they were not pressured to make games in time for the holidays.
Versus a lot of the more recent games coming out.
More camels!
It was before capitalism decided to take over the world.
Whoa!
Intensive treatment!
Warden... that's not true!
I can go with him.
I don't know... I feel like, Batman... you are a billionaire... I don't know, I feel this should be
The games were so much simpler when it came to settings.
This is it.
What the fuck?
That's it?
Those are all my settings?
Oh my god, those are all my settings.
Holy shit.
Okay, I did not expect my settings to be like...
Not that much.
Holy shit.
Yeah, I feel like there's a lot of like...
Uh...
Like funding wise...
It feels like...
I don't know.
It feels like Arkham Asylum.
Someone is taking too much of the funding from Arkham Asylum.
Oh my god.
Okay, turn down voices by like 40...
Turn down music by 40%.
And then...
And then 100% on the sound.
Okay, thank you soundcheck guy.
Just use your mod powers to tell me things.
Alright.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
That's crazy.
I didn't realize there was like...
These were all the settings.
I forgot games were a lot simpler back then.
There was like six things.
Whoa.
Okay.
Not gonna lie...
If we were gonna talk about budget cuts...
This would be one of the things I would cut.
I have every approval of that station here today.
So...
I hope it's a...
Oh, lord.
Do we really need a picture of you?
Like...
Curing him?
It's the fucking Joker.
It's been like...
60 plus years.
I don't think...
After 60 plus years that we will ever cure Joker.
Look at all this new security.
He's so happy.
The warden?
Hahaha.
Alright, I was gonna say, I think you gotta have a better standards.
Do we really need this elevator?
Stairs would work.
That is such a small elevator.
Stairs would actually work.
Or like a ramp.
We could have had a ramp.
Oh my god, okay.
Batman, financial wise, this building is terrible financial wise.
He's on it!
That's what ramps are for!
That was like barely one meter.
Oh,
zoom.
What am I zooming in for?
Oh, him?
This actually, the graphics actually age so well.
It's called Tax Cuts.
I want weapons on him at all times.
Do not let him out of your sight.
There'll be time enough for you later, Cash.
Speak your time.
Tick tock, tick tock.
Is that a crocodile I hear?
Croc?
What's up, Doc?
Pencil me in for tomorrow, please.
We've always, always fought.
We've got a lot of catching up to do.
Where can I run?
Keep behind me.
Hello new patient.
Krafftink.
Yeah, everything age so well for a game that was fourteen years ago.
Do we really need this TV?
Okay, financial wise, like, do we really need all of this?
Do we really need a TV?
At 5, 10 steps away?
Warden!
What are the millions of dollars I fucking pledged for this asylum for?
Shut up!
No, catch you soon, boss!
Shut it and keep moving!
The state of the wiring!
This is so poorly run.
This is...
This is... This is... Oh, now there's stairs!
Just be quick!
I like how, like, now there's a use for stairs.
Satisfactory condition.
Looks like he suffered minor lacerations probably in the last two hours.
There seems to be...
Whoa!
Need to take my temperature?
I'd be happy to drop my pants.
I mean, I did just capture him.
He's good.
But that sweater is like, minor lacerations.
But how's the sound now, Soundcheck guy?
He ran out...
Was that C-Blum?
Oh my god!
I love C-Blum.
He's like, he has the best IMO.
I think he is the best Starscream voice actor.
You heard the lady!
We got another one!
There's another Psycho on the way!
There's another Psycho?
You hear that, Joker?
You're not fucking special.
No?
Where the fuck is that?
Must have been one of the guards then.
Is that another elevator?
Crock-o-boy!
Is that you?
Where the fuck is that?
Wait, who the fuck is that?
Is that Crock?
Get ready.
Where the fuck... Where's his guard?
What is he doing?
They let him in the elevator unsupervised?
Okay, Joker has like ten guards on him, but Crock has zero.
I don't know.
Priorities wise.
Killer Crock.
What's it doing?
Yeah, how did he get here?
I've got your scent, Batman.
Who the fuck put him in the elevator by himself?
Get that animal under control!
Oh shit!
I got two!
Toy collar won't stop me from killing you, Batman.
I'll rip you apart.
Eat your bones.
I like how... I...
Okay, okay, now he gets two guards.
Okay, the guy that's like, you know, not restrained gets two guards.
Okay.
I mean, would you be in an elevator with him?
I don't know.
I feel like it's very dangerous...
to like have a villain...
by himself on an elevator for that long.
Unsupervised in general.
I feel like that's like, in hindsight, that doesn't sound very smart.
The night is young, Bats.
I still have a trick or two up my sleeve.
I mean, don't you think it's a little bit funny how a fire at Blackgate caused hundreds of my crew to be moved here?
I thought I told you to stay quiet!
Yeah.
Oh, Frankie.
You really should learn to keep that fat mouth of yours shut.
You're such a mess.
Also, I really don't think you should antagonize Joker.
Tell me something.
You've never let me catch you this easily.
What are you really after?
Well, nothing much.
Hundreds dying in pain here.
Why a second elevator?
There's a lot of...
Why two TV screens?
You're asking about a second elevator?
But why are there two TV screens?
I think you should avoid the fact that the prisoners from Blackgate Prison...
I think...
Guys, there's a lot more questions to ask here.
Huh?
What's he doing?
Stay where you are.
Get a flashlight!
Get a light out of here!
Guys, maybe we shouldn't have two TV...
Wha...
I wasn't sure that you should be a step-bringer.
What?
Don't you trust me?
Of course not.
You're fucking Joker.
You're a fucking Joker.
You...
Batman literally was like, I've never caught you this easily before.
Oh, hey, look.
See more guards.
You're back.
You killed three of my crew when you busted out of here.
Okay, wait.
Let me bring up the overall sound first.
We gotta do justice to Mark Hamill.
Let me boost up the sound a little bit more.
Alright.
I hope this is better sound, guy.
The budget went to the TVs.
Oh.
Gordon?
Is this Commissioner Gordon?
Long night, Jim.
Joker invades City Hall and holds the mayor hostage.
Leaving it to me to juggle SWAT teams, the media, and you.
Yeah, it's been a hell of a night.
Hopefully the last one we'll ever have with him.
Harley?
Hold it there.
Sorry, Batman.
Arkham staff only.
I assure you, if anyone's qualified, it's me.
Listen, I appreciate the assistance, but he'll unsettle the more violent inmates.
I think he's talking about you, Bats.
Don't be a stranger.
You're always welcome here.
Well, to be fair, they are right.
I mean, I'm pretty sure Batman put all these criminals in the asylum.
You okay?
He surrendered almost without a fight.
I don't like it.
At least he's back where he belongs.
Yeah, I agree.
Yeah, for like, I don't know, the 50th time he's in the asylum.
I feel like Joker should be like one of the villains that should just be like, be in a prison just built for him.
Batman, there's a door!
Oh, fuck!
There's a door!
Batman, I set a trap and you sprang it gloriously!
Now let's get this party started.
Ladies and men.
Alright.
I apologize for this interruption to your regular inter- Easy.
Wait, are normal grunts in the asylum too?
I'm just gonna heal everyone in the room.
Okay, honestly, I don't know what the grunts were thinking if that was smart.
Alright, I know you were- No!
Not done!
I'm not satisfied!
Oh there you go, thanks!
I'm not satisfied, get over here!
Avoid damage by countering incoming- Who needs to counter when I could just beat up everybody?
There's no need to counter when they're all dead.
The bug staffer!
I feel like it's more like the bat staffer.
No.
Alright.
Nice.
I don't run.
No.
Oh.
Who?
Alright.
I honestly feel like the asylum should not have like regular guys in here.
Is there a way to run?
Batman, please!
Can you only fucking walk?
Oh, okay.
Apparently prowling is faster.
Okay.
Wait, I could have literally had the door!
What the fuck?
Did I smash the window?
They had keys!
Wait!
Oh, I can walk!
I can run as A!
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I had to...
I had to like test that out for a sec.
What's the bio?
Police Commissioner James Gwinn.
A former warden dedicated his career to cleaning up the corruption in the Gotham City Police Department.
A goal he has come long towards accomplishing.
He has been equally tough on crime and in pursuit of making Gotham City safe for all his citizens.
Gordon has forged an uneasy alliance with Gotham's other top crime fighter, the mysterious vigilante known as Batman!
Oh shit.
Oh, there's the warden.
Wait, what are his facts?
Oh shit, I'm gonna dox him.
Um, James W.
Gordon!
White formerly?
Okay.
Oh, that's interesting.
Wait, what's the Joker's real name?
Unknown?!
What the fuck?
What's the point?
What about his medical records?
How is he gonna pay his medical bills?
Plague Gotham City.
He is currently campaigning to become the next mayor of Gotham.
Oh yeah, he definitely...
He's definitely money laundering.
Yeah, this guy definitely looks like a guy that money launders and bezels money.
Are they okay?
They can't be dead.
No one kills.
Oh, now they tell me how to run.
Nice.
Warning.
Security breach in level B3.
There's no security... I'm Batman!
Warning.
Security breach in level B4.
How can there be security breach if I'm Batman?
Warning.
Security breach in level B8.
Nice.
Alright.
Warning.
Security breach in level B1.
Where do I go?
Oh shit!
How are you still not dead?
Warning.
Security breach in level B6.
Goodbye.
Warning.
Security breach in level B4.
These guys have like zero armor.
They should not be like...
They should not take this long to beat up.
The Oracle!
He's running free in Arkham.
Do you need anything?
Is my dad still there?
Commissioner Gordon is safe.
Wait, then where's this way?
Okay.
Which way is the right way?
Alright, where's this?
This goes...
Pacification chamber.
Where does this go?
Contamination.
Oh shit.
Are you a good guy?
Hey Batman!
Over here!
Hello!
Eddie!
Why do you have a name?
I'm not supposed to humanize you.
You're just an NPC.
What happened?
Joker happened.
You're lucky to be alive.
He must have gone this way.
Door is jammed.
I'll try and get it open.
Oh yeah, I know.
I know she can't walk anymore.
Can you hear me?
I'm with Batman.
Hello?
Where are they?
Back down there.
Do you need help?
No.
I work better alone.
Yeah.
And also the 500 adopted sons.
And two adopted daughters.
I always...
Okay, so if you guys don't know...
Okay, Robin is not the original Robin.
Dick is not the original Robin.
They like retconned and was like...
There was actually one more.
I forgot her name.
But she was...
There was a female Robin before Dick Robin.
And...
So now...
Now there's two adopted daughters and 500 adopted sons.
He works alone.
Third?
There's three adopted daughters?
He's strapped in the chair.
Saz has totally lost it.
Wait here.
You can't.
He'll kill Mike if he sees anyone trying to get close.
He won't see me.
Anything that looks even a little bit like a bat...
And this guard dies.
Do you hear me?
We can just get another guard.
He doesn't have a name.
Look at the pig.
What happens if I just run up?
Okay.
Alright, that happens.
Alright.
But he's nameless.
It doesn't matter.
He has no name.
Does it really matter?
What happens to him?
There's three?
Who the fuck is the third Robin?
Okay.
I guess I throw the batter at him?
That's what I do.
Alright.
Oh.
Okay.
Boop.
Oh.
Wait.
Do I fail?
What?
No!
It's just one guy!
Who cares?
We don't even know his name!
We can just pay him.
The hostage was killed.
I'm a billionaire!
I can just pay his family!
I can compensate his family!
What?
Just one guy.
I'm a billionaire!
I can just...
I can just raise his family!
He doesn't even have a name!
Why should we care?
His name is literally guard!
His name was Mike.
Okay.
Why the fuck are you focusing on names now?
I'm just filming on the ground, so I'll stay up high.
Yeah.
I have to use detective mode.
What's this?
Whoa!
Okay.
Look around for some important objects.
Oh!
Can I...
do something about that?
These old gargoyles should be able to support my weight if I grapple up to them.
Okay.
Gargoyles provide a suitable vantage point from which to survey a room.
Oh!
It's okay.
He's just getting zapped a little bit.
Glide cake.
To perform a glide cake by focusing on the camera.
Okay.
But what if he like zaps him a little bit more?
It's Mike from 20 years ago!
Give him a little bit of a zap.
Oh!
Shit!
Bro, I just made him a fucking vegetable!
But he's not dead!
He's...
He's not dead!
Oh
shit!
It's the fucking embezzler!
Oh shit!
Old Sharp has never been happier!
In case you ain't figured it out, today is the Joker's big homecoming and you're the guest of honor!
You have one chance to surrender, Quinn.
Tempting baths, but no dice.
Now the...
Technically the Joker's grooms shipped him from Blackgate.
But you get the idea!
Oh!
How is it you're gonna give me more updates?
Batman, you picking this up?
Harley Quinn.
This is Harleen Quinzel.
An Arkham Asylum psychiatrist assigned to treat the Joker.
Dr. Harleen Quinzel instead became excessively fixated on her patient, believing herself to be in love with him.
She helped him escape confinement and took on her...
I can fix her!
And took on her own criminal identity as Harley Quinn.
Quinn is a violent and unpredictable felon who's only...
Not the fucking $500,000 TV's that we fucking funded for the asylum!
No!
Don't worry.
That's why we have four TV's per week.
Um...
Because cruel in nature distanced away makes her just another of his victims.
A very dangerous one.
I'm here.
Arkham Asylum just vanished off the network.
He's in control of the security system.
He's probably isolated it from the grid.
That's not all
one sets foot on Arkham Island.
How the fuck?
Now they figured out?
But the story will break anytime now.
Also, who the fuck wants to live in Gotham anymore?
How do you know?
I know.
I swear to god.
I feel like Gotham City has like the cheapest properties.
Because like...
It feels so depressing to live in Gotham City.
At this point.
Like...
I don't know.
After like...
I feel like the average death rate in Gotham City is like at least like 500...
What the fuck?
I'm so fast.
Is like...
500 per day.
Where the fuck are they still?
At this point.
I just live where Superman lives.
Like...
At least he can kill.
I live in a city where superheroes actually kill.
Yeah!
That's like a no kill bullshit.
It's just Chicago.
I'll live wherever... I'll be like, do you kill?
Alright, nice.
Oh shit, are they dead?
Oh no, it's the laughing gas.
You can't afford Metropole!
Anyway, let's open it.
Alright, how do I do this?
Oh, grapple?
Where?
Whoops.
Sucks to be them, I guess.
What happens if they all... can they actually all die?
Just walk away!
Just stop looking!
Sir, look away!
Stop!
It's just drama!
You don't have to look!
Oh, they can?
Oh shit, I was looking too hard.
You can?
You're gonna let Steve die?
Who gives a fuck about Steve?
He doesn't even have a name!
He's literally guard!
Oh shit!
Where the fuck do I get up here?
Batman's here!
Just hold on a little longer, Steve!
Oh shit, Steve!
I'm gonna fall!
Where's Steve?
Steve was trying to reach the vent controls and clear the room when the explosion happened.
Please, I care about Steve!
Alright, but how do I get the Riddler trophy?
Steve!
Steve, look, I'm sorry, but there is important matters.
Like, how do I get this trophy?
Okay, we gotta go downstairs.
But then there's laughing gas, so we gotta figure out how to not get laughing gas.
Look up.
Look!
I need to figure out the gas!
Oh, there's Steve!
There he is!
Trophy over Steve!
Yes, I've never been a completionist, but today's the day I change.
You're the worst Batman ever?
Look!
Batman has already been the worst Batman ever because he doesn't kill.
Okay...
If he killed Joker ten years ago, we would not be here.
So, no matter what I do, Batman is already the worst Batman he can be.
Yay...
Alright, cut over here.
Oh, God!
I don't kill, but I do get brain damage.
Clearly... Clearly, that's the best alternative.
Use to remove toxins... Okay, but how do I remove it?
Terminal use...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
Okay... Sorry, I tripped.
I tripped.
Everything's okay.
Okay.
Um...
Smash glass to activate it.
Can I just smash it like this?
Nice.
Sorry.
Okay.
I tripped.
Yay!
I did it!
Casualty's not that bad.
Alright, now I can get the trophy.
I did it!
Yeah!
Look at that!
Sucks for all those other guys that died, but woo!
I did it!
Yeah!
Okay, how the fuck do I get the trophy?
It's somewhere here.
Ow.
Okay.
Where is this?
Where's the op switch?
Oh, there it is.
Can I just punch it?
No?
Where's the other guard?
Hey there!
Destroy the teeth?
Why?
What's the teeth do to you?
Can I destroy it actually?
Wait, I can!
Whoops.
How many batarangs do I have?
Unlimited?
Oh, wait.
What is that?
Plus 50?
Is that my currency?
You need a gadget that you don't have yet?
I'm Batman!
What do you mean I don't have yet?
I have money!
I can fix all my problems with money!
Oh wait, there's another one.
Oh!
Did I get it?
Oh, I did.
Nice.
Okay.
I wish I knew that earlier.
Backseaters!
You could have told me this earlier!
It's in there.
Those are the batbucks.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, is that the laughing gas?
Okay.
Causing a slow and painful death.
Oops.
Haha.
What the fuck gave him pink cans?
Oh, bat teeth!
Oops.
Sorry.
Thank god they're unlimited.
My budget.
50 million on batarangs.
Alright, guys.
Someone help me budget this.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
I wish Batman has guns.
There you go.
He dead?
Oh, he is definitely dead.
Oh fuck, he is definitely dead.
Nice.
Gotham City is sometimes like New Jersey.
I...
Wait.
Any New Jersey people out there want a fucking vouch for that?
What the fuck gave Joker spray cans?
Oh, teeth.
No!
Teeth!
Oh, now I can't aim.
After 200 years.
Who's that?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck is this guy?
Boom.
Double tap direction to evade.
Holy shit!
You can just throw people?
Ow!
Okay.
Evade.
Where the fuck...
What do I do?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Don't worry.
I have unlimited batarangs.
What is he gonna do?
Fucking punch me?
It's fine.
This is my gun now.
Use your fist.
Why use my fist when I can throw batarangs?
Oh shit!
How the fuck is my fist stronger than metal?
Like...
You're right.
Just call Superman.
Honestly, I feel like all my problems could just be fixed if I call Superman.
Like, I need to make sure... Like, pride and ego should not be...
Wait.
Was that it?
Oh, fuck.
Well, that was unexpected, wasn't it?
Well, well.
Note to self.
Need stronger test subjects.
Seeing as how I'm feeling generous, I'll give you this...
How is my fist stronger than fucking metal?
I dare you.
End this.
Pull the button.
I feel wonderful for all.
From sheer physics, my batarangs should be stronger.
Physics wa... That's a blade!
Oh, you're getting too predictable, Vance.
Well, I'd love to stay and chat, but I have a lot of work to do.
I'm gonna go to a party to organize...
Throw your batarangs!
I'm gonna get a bat from all the stars!
Batman, what are you doing?
He can't dodge five!
He got the money punch.
Batman is a Batr...
Yeah, this does not look natural.
Yeah, it's not natural.
Oh, shit.
Ow.
I can upgrade!
Alright, congratulations.
You have unlocked a Wayne Tech upgrade.
Uh, Batman ignores physics.
Okay.
It's like...
Bat...
Doki is backstab...
Yes, because it's stupid!
Why did he throw his batarangs?
He could have ended it all!
I don't know if he doesn't want to kill it and fucking throw it at his fucking leg or some shit!
Like, it doesn't have to be lethal.
Okay, fill the XP meter to upgrade the Bat-Soon.
Gain enhanced skills.
Yes, Wayne Tech.
Alright.
Wayne Tech...
Oh, wait.
That's the map.
Oh my god!
Thank god there's a map!
I'm always...
directionally challenged.
Alright.
What do we...
Oh, it's just a linear upgrade.
Oh, wait.
No.
No, there's not.
Okay.
Combo Batarang.
Critical combo strikes.
Alright, what do we...
Backseaters!
Rise up!
What do we upgrade first?
Backseaters!
This is it!
What do we upgrade first?
This is your time to shine!
There's so many stuff.
Inverted takedown?
The fuck is that?
Remote control Batarang?
Sorry, apparently fucking physics sucks in this game.
That Batarang's mean nothing.
Inverted takedown.
Okay.
Allows Batman to swoop down and grab a stainless as they pass under gargoyles and...
and leave the... Oh!
Wait, that's so cool.
Okay.
I can just like...
be up top.
And not have to worry.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, pick up the Riddler trophy.
Is there anything else here?
Detective mode.
Anything else I'm missing?
Who's this?
Is this Eddie?
Eddie!
Oh, god.
Sorry.
You don't matter, too.
Wait, he literally has Eddie's eyes!
...Jerry in here.
Powered up the gate.
Oh, Jerry has a name.
Joker went through that door.
What's on the other side?
We call it extreme isolation.
Only way in is via the transport system.
I love how they gave Jerry a name, but not guard number 20.
Alright.
Nice.
Thank you, guard.
The main security loop is locked.
Can I go back and grab the teeth?
No!
Joker.
You were expecting maybe two fates.
There's no escape, Joker.
Silly bat!
I don't want to escape them having way too much fun!
I even have you here to give a smile on my face!
Not for long.
Really?
We'll see.
This is a very unhealthy relationship, Joker.
Just in case you were planning to arrange a little insurance.
What the fuck?
Gordon!
No!
Officer Bowles.
Officer Bowles is corrupt?
Gordon, your whole job was to deal with corruption!
If you try to follow me, he dies.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, Gordon's terrible at his job, too.
Gordon, your one fucking job was to deal with corruption!
How did this happen?
I don't know.
Alright, we gotta go locate an allies to hold themselves for evidence.
Alright.
I gotta look at that map a lot.
Where's the teeth?
Batman, what's happening?
No, my XP!
Joker's escaped.
He sealed himself off.
He's got your father.
Dad.
Don't worry, I'm getting him back.
He's doing his best.
At this point, I feel like we have to hire another commissioner.
Joker will not win.
I won't let him.
I'm starting where he was taken.
Gord is not rich enough to be good at his job.
If he was a good cop, he would not be stationed at Gotham City.
If you think about it...
If you think about it, he would have 100% been promoted outside of Gotham City.
Wait, do I have enough to upgrade for anything else?
No, I don't.
He would have been stationed in Metropolis.
How do you do it?
Not gonna lie...
Batman should never... I should not have the title of Great Detective with my track record.
What
the fuck is... How corrupt is this place?
Batman!
Just have better funding!
You're literally a billionaire!
Outsource... Outsource to Metropolis to get...
Is that actually too hard to do?
Just throw money at the problem!
Outsource!
Oh hey, the penguin!
Iceberg lounge.
Very hard.
Two hostiles?
Oh, they're over there.
Okay.
Three TVs.
Wait, that's true!
Why the fuck was there three TVs?!
He can't outfund the embezzlement.
Shit, you're fucking right.
This is a bigger issue than it should be.
Oh, throw a bat instantly at end time.
Use a quick throw?
Wait, how do I use...
Oh, okay, I just do that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
God, my fucking Batarangs are so weak!
Brain damage!
Alright.
Goodbye!
There's a lot of issues.
There is.
This is a huge problem, Batman.
This is a huge problem.
Oracle, I'm at the holding cells.
I'm setting up a crime scene.
So what's the plan?
Isolate something in that room unique to both?
Exactly.
In a crime scene use detective mode to search for evidence.
Okay.
Evidence scanner.
Am I scanning?
Aborted?
Okay, I'm scanning?
Whaaaam?
Why the fuck do I need a scan?
I'm in the right place.
Ow.
Isolate something I can link to the guard that clubbed Gordon.
Wait, where did he get clubbed?
Oh, there you go!
What the fuck is that?
Let's see what the forensic scanner picks up.
Alcohol?
Gordon, were you drinking?
Oracle, I've got a trail.
That's great.
You follow it.
I'm grabbing...
This is why you got fucking clubbed!
Hey, uh...
Track Gordon moves by following Bulls...
Oh, no.
He was drinking.
He had alcohol strength.
I see.
He's detected mo...
Oh?
Anything else?
Oh, I see.
Disease?
Who the fuck is that?
Use detective mode to follow...
Wait, there's more?
The whiskey trails?
Where the fuck is the whiskey trails?
I literally see one whiskey...
Oh, there it is!
Ow.
Okay, let's just fucking...
Can I chop this?
Boom.
No, I cannot.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm thinking.
Break the window.
The window's already broken.
Can I jump out?
No.
Okay, now I can't jump out.
Alright.
No scanning?
Let me cook.
Don't worry, I'll figure this out.
I'm the greatest detective.
Don't worry.
Like they said.
I'm the fucking greatest detective.
I'm the greatest detective out there.
Oh!
Alright, there's more alcohol.
There we go.
I'm figuring it out, guys.
...staff with correct security clearance.
Security levels are now at orange alpha.
There's more here.
...alpha.
I'm following it.
Oh my god, Joker.
He's a computer engineer too?
He can hack things?
Oh my god, he can do everything.
Oh.
Enemy?
Are you a good guy?
I can't see.
I'm in detective mode.
How did Joker get- Be quiet.
What's going on?
Jerry, is that you?
Be quiet.
I'm detectiving.
Ah ah ah ah!
B-man!
Mr. J doesn't want you following us just yet.
I missed teeth?
No!
Not the teeth!
Oh, shit.
I can fix her.
I don't feel like my daddy.
No way to follow us now.
Where's the teeth?
Oh, teeth!
Give me a sec, Harley.
Harley, I literally have grapple.
...service in the elevator.
If I want to follow them, I'll need to do this the old-fashioned way.
Harley, I literally have grappling.
How is that gonna stop me, Harley?
Wait, wait.
Where do stairs go?
Wait, there's stairs?
Harley, there's stairs!
Oh my god, you have a name!
Henry Smith!
Who else?
I told them, he's a monster!
It's Slug!
I'm slower than them!
Alright.
Let's see.
You know what?
Let's try with grapple first.
It's faster than stairs.
I feel like that is a lot faster.
Unless...
Wait.
Are you trying to tell me there's no more else to grapple?
No!
Then what's the point?
What?
Chimmy?
Ooh.
Alright.
Can I...
Go here?
I know you can hear me.
I've got a little something for you to listen to.
What is it, Joker?
Harley and Frank are...
Let's have a listen, shall we?
Hey Frank, where you been?
Joker's got more men on the way.
They're coming around the front of the asylum.
Gotta stop them getting in quick!
Get over there!
Damn!
Come on, everyone, cover the main entrance!
Ooh!
Hang on, help me, help me, help me!
This is important.
Oh!
Frank, what are you doing?
The corruption!
Frank, what the hell?
Quit!
It's clear!
Get your ass in here!
You're some piece of work, Frankie!
Wait, is Joker a c- No!
Sounds like Frankie's looking out just fine.
No!
Oh, I'm alive!
Okay, everything's fine.
Yay!
They're killing me!
No!
Okay,
let's see.
Let's shoot me again, Joker.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna say...
That's a little awkward.
How the fuck do I get to the fucking...
Riddler trophy?
Does it really matter?
Okay, guys.
Other than for achievements, what does the trophy get me?
What does the trophy get me other than achievements?
I need to know.
Just for unlocks?
What does it unlock?
Nothing.
Okay.
I'll never look at another trophy.
Oh, XP?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I need XP, actually.
Never mind.
XP is nice.
Run towards low walls or fences to climb them?
Oh, like this?
Nice.
Alright.
Let's see...
God, I'm so confused right now.
There's too many entrances!
The feeling of accomplishment!
Look, I'm already doing it for the achievements.
I mean, I've already done it for the achievements.
I'm already doing it for the XP, okay!
Is that not enough?
I don't know.
I'm going to go through.
There's so many areas to go to.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Holly, why the fuck did you- I should have taken the stairs.
I should've taken the stairs!
God...
God fucking damn it!
The stairs would have been easier.
The stairs would have been...
100% easier.
Where am I?
Where?
Oh shit!
What is this?
It's a fake wall!
That I can't do anything about!
What the fuck?
What?
How do I...
How do I destroy it?
Structurally weak.
If it's structurally weak, why would my fist destroy it?
Control... Oh, it's for later.
God damn it, it's for later?
God damn it.
Alright.
Guess I won't have to go there yet.
I don't have the upgrades, guys.
I'm poor, apparently.
Skate?
Oh.
I did it.
Might not...
I did not do it.
I did not do it!
Oh shit!
No, they're alive.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Where do I go?
Shimmy?
Wait, oh, shimmy!
Oh my god, there's a shimmy!
I'm learning.
Guys, I'm getting better.
Why didn't they appoint...
fucking...
supermen in Gotham City?
I feel like I'm just in the wrong city at this point.
I feel like if the crime rate is like 80%, I think I'm doing...
I think my... I'm not doing a very good job.
I don't think I was meant to be a superhero.
Just think about it, guys.
Warning.
Arkham Intensive Treatment is at code...
If the crime rate is still so fucking high, then what's the point?
Think!
Maybe he's actually not good at what he does.
Warning.
Arkham Intensive Treatment is under emergency lockdown.
What's the joke if Harley is evil?
Why?
Because only evil people are high.
Let's see...
Oh, there it is!
Jesus Christ.
It's a gun.
Woop!
Alright, I got it.
I figured it out.
I'm slowly learning.
Also, where the fuck is Robin?
Is this before I had kids?
What's this?
What is that?
Is this another thing I need to upgrade?
Hold and scan.
Oh!
Deciphered messages.
Okay.
I need to steal more kids?
True.
Oh shit!
Alright, where is it?
Backseaters, it's your time.
Okay.
Hello.
Alright.
Time to beat up goo number five.
Oh.
Alright.
Hey, look.
Billionaires are not supposed to be like good fighters.
We just throw money at things.
Oh shit!
Alright.
Goodbye.
Where's my gun update?
Nope.
Tee.
Alright, tee.
Oh, vent.
There's like so many passageways around here.
I'm getting so confused.
There's a lot.
Okay, locked, locked.
Nice alcohol.
Alright, we have to go to the vent then.
Oh no, I feel like I'm gonna get more lost later.
I have a feeling.
Please.
Woah, shit!
Wait, he has gun?
Alright, I don't have to.
Wait, who's that?
I don't want to.
Okay, boss, there's no one getting past.
Is that fair?
You've got it.
Anyone coming?
Batman!
Is it people are dying and you don't want to use a gun?
Okay, it should be a life for life.
If they get to kill two people, I get to kill two people.
Like, I feel like...
No, I can run.
Oh shit, I cannot run!
I'm not faster than a bullet.
Guys, I found out Batman's not faster than bullets.
It's great, they can't walk forward.
Oh, Fargoil.
Okay.
Let's see.
Gargoyle.
Okay.
Tap down.
Drop down silently.
But what if I can kill?
But I want to kill!
Okay, but like, what if I do this?
Nice.
What are you gonna do?
Oh shit!
No, that's not silent!
Okay, but what if I do this?
Oh!
I don't think they like that.
I don't think...
Okay.
Wait, they're not...
God damn it, my battery ran so fucking weak.
No!
What the...
Okay.
Woooooo!
What the hell?
They will never know.
But...
They'll never know.
Hey.
I wonder where Batman is.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Ahhhhh!
Sorry.
I got a little cocky there.
Shhhhhh.
Okay.
That's a little stupid.
I can't lie.
That's a little fucking stupid.
Wait, there's a person there.
They'll never know.
Yes, we need to set a trap!
Yes,
we need to set a trap!
I love surprises!
I know I think they'll enjoy it too.
I mean, they already have guns.
Don't worry, they'll be fine.
Developed by Wayne Tech.
Are you considered hack-proof?
Currently inactive.
That's a fucking lie!
The Joker literally hacked several things!
What do you mean?
Wayne Tech.
Wayne Tech!
You are not...
I'm not a great billionaire.
To be fair, I feel like...
I like...
As Bruce Wayne, I definitely outsource everything.
There's no way I have enough time to run a fucking company if I'm a fucking billionaire.
I'm out here doing all this.
Alright.
What do we need to upgrade?
Welcome to corporate America.
How many goddamn TV this asylum has?
Look.
There's a lot of things wrong with Gotham City in general.
Alright, guys.
It's time!
It's time, backseaters.
Times two combo?
Which one?
Where is it?
Critical strike?
Where is that?
What we've learned is that batterhands don't fucking work.
Okay.
Which one is the best one?
Armor?
Critical strikes?
Wait, next to inverted?
Oh, there we go.
Wait, I don't have enough.
How much is that?
I'm broke?
Sorry, guys.
I don't have enough money apparently.
How much XP are this?
There's no...
I have a thousand batbucks!
A thousand dollars is...
Okay, what the fuck is the exchange rate of batbucks?
Apparently the batbucks exchange rate is pretty fucking poor right now.
Uncle Jay!
Oh
my dangerous, I don't even have a gun!
I don't even...
Okay, I don't even kill.
I should not be dangerous at all if I can't even kill.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Oh.
I just slapped him once and that's good.
But, let's see.
Oh, you guys are the best!
I'm a bat!
Yeah.
I'll give you orders and then sit in your nice, safe room while we fight Batman.
Alright, how do I kill this guy?
Inverted takedown!
There it is!
What are you doing?
Nice.
Okay, not gonna lie, this can actually kill a person.
Not gonna lie.
Batman, you idiot!
If you...
If they leave hanging way too long, the blood will go all the way to the head!
And then he'll die!
Hey!
Batman!
Oh, shit!
It's just a slower death, Batman!
Don't you understand?
Oh, he doesn't look up.
Gamers don't look up.
No, no, it'll be fine.
Don't worry.
He doesn't look up, right?
Ooh, glad kick.
It's fine.
It's Oski.
Who's gonna let him down?
There's no guards here!
Batman, he's gonna get up!
His heart's gonna stop!
Batman!
Gravity killed him!
Not Batman!
That's true.
It's not my fault.
It's Gravity's fault.
Gamers don't look up.
Oh, shit!
Please!
I'm still beating someone up!
No!
Okay.
That was a mistake.
That's a sleeping.
Someone finish him off.
No, Joker!
You can't finish me off!
Okay, wait.
Freezing.
Sorry.
Wait, where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Where am I?
Where is this place?
I don't know where I am.
Oh, it's this one!
That dude is all over again!
Are you fucking...
Okay, I have to listen to him.
It's fine.
There's no way he'll...
Oh, it's this one!
I can hear this.
It's fine.
He doesn't hear this.
Don't worry.
They learned how to look up in the third...
Wait, you mean they actually learned?
What a matter this misery.
It's the only reliable cure.
To be fair, I think that is what Joker wants though.
How the fuck he does his stuff.
I'm just glad I kicked this guy.
Whoop!
Get over here.
I really am.
Oh!
No!
Stop!
Is he still shooting?
I thought they don't look up!
Wait, where did he go?
Where is he?
He was a glad kick.
How the fuck do they have guns now?
Things were so easy.
I didn't think it was gonna be that easy.
Yeah.
I sent a few more of my boys your way.
Let's see how you deal with these.
Alright, where are the other ones?
Joker wants him found.
Spread out!
He could be anywhere.
Then keep your eyes open.
Is this supposed to be a stealth section?
No, we don't stealth here.
If we learn how Doki plays.
There's no...
Wait, why am I not on the gargoyle?
I'm not on the gargoyle.
There's no such thing as stealth.
Alright, let's see.
They won't know I'm up here, right?
Okay, get over here.
Get over here.
Come on.
Walk over here.
Gravity will kill you.
Come on!
It won't be so bad.
That's right.
No, no, no.
Come on.
Right here.
Ah!
Just a little to the left.
You're almost there.
Are you okay?
Alright.
He doesn't want to...
I don't think he wants to...
Alright, don't worry.
I got this one over here.
Alright.
Come on.
A little to the right.
You know you want to...
Throw a bat around...
I'm not gonna throw a bat around.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Here, here.
Come on.
You have to...
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Nice.
I told you eventually.
Eventually it'd work.
What is he gonna do?
Look up?
Or do I just walk over to the other side?
What are we gonna do?
Yeah, what are we gonna do?
What is he gonna do?
Wait, can they cut it down?
Just shoot the rope.
We'll come back when the bat is dead.
We'll come back, okay.
Shoot the rope.
Just shoot the rope.
Alright, nice.
Now he's gonna walk to me.
Oh, I can cut the rope?
Oh my god, this changes everything.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's paranoid.
Nice.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Brain damage.
Oh no.
That's his dick.
Okay.
That's a little bit worse.
Oh, interview.
Call me Harley.
Everyone does.
Thank you for the super chat.
Congrats on 550k subscribers.
Thank you!
I can't believe we broke 500k subscribers.
I warn you right now.
These are hardcore psychos.
I would rather kill you than speak to you.
One or two of them will enjoy it too.
Be careful.
Oh shit, the Riddler?
I never got to meet him.
Oh my god.
I recently watched the new Batman movie with Robert Patterson.
And like, okay.
Okay, the Riddler's fucking outfit.
I was like, why the fuck is he wearing BDSM gear?
I was like, this is like a movie.
Is that a GIMP?
I can open doors?
Oh wait, no.
What?
Where?
Oh!
It's like stealth.
Yeah, like the new...
The Riddler in that new Batman...
I don't fuck with his outfit.
I don't know.
Just ain't right for him.
I'm saying.
You're wrong.
Oh no!
Like, his...
I don't know.
I just...
I don't... It made me very uncomfortable.
The fuck?
Oh shit, is that him?
Who's that over there?
Whoops, sorry.
Who's that?
Deceased.
Do you think...
Do you think the other guy's okay?
Dead end.
Oh shit!
Track Gordon's moving by following Bull's whiskey trails.
Let me grab some tea first.
Can I like do it fast?
No.
Oh I can!
Nice.
Oh yes, but I don't kill.
Can we take my fucking ass?
What the fuck?
Wait tech!
You complete a series of amusingly taxing challenges and well, you'll see.
Ready for your first one?
What's my first one?
But be careful.
Don't cut yourself on this sharply observed portrait.
This?
Object detected?
I said, don't cut yourself on this sharply observed portrait.
This is a sharply observed portrait.
Oh shit!
Did the stream die?
It's okay, I'm back.
Where the fuck?
What other portraits are there?
What are they?
No!
Oh I'm back.
Okay, the riddler broke the screen.
But don't worry, we're back.
Oh!
Is it this portrait?
There's another portrait right here.
Oh wait, no not that one.
Yeah!
You did it!
Well done!
I would have expected a child to work that one out, let alone the world's greatest detective.
What did I win?
What the fuck did I win?
What is it?
You don't know Jack about utility corridor.
You don't know Jack about Gotham.
Tune in to find out.
What did I win?
Riddler, what the fuck did I win?
Okay, let's see.
Do I have enough to upgrade yet?
Oh, I need like $20.
Oh, XP?
I love XP.
Anything else I can do?
Hello.
Do you have a name?
Oh my god, William!
William in gate.
Two of my guys moved to the exit and Frank shot him dead.
They never stood a chance.
Was Bowles alone?
Thought he was.
Then I saw Harley Quinn.
She was surrounded by Black Gate prisoners.
They were just killing every last one of them.
No!
I had no choice.
I got in here, locked the door.
Don't worry, William.
I'll never kill like them.
Even though all your friends are dead.
Most of outlived is useful.
Good.
He was scum.
Don't worry.
I'll look after Maria.
Who the fuck is Maria?
Oh my god, you're gonna take his wife?
Bro, what the fuck?
He's dead!
That's fucked up, man.
Don't worry, my best friend.
Maria.
You'll be safe with me.
That's messed up.
I don't think he would want you to take care of her.
How do I get over there?
Oh.
God damn it.
I'm still weak as fuck.
Anything here?
No.
Uh...
I had no choice.
No!
John!
You're dead!
Anyway...
Now I feel like he wanted him to be dead.
I apologize for this interruption.
Jack Ryder.
Who the fuck is Jack Ryder?
Scan.
Joker!
No, scan.
Scan!
And you can all consider...
Call his bluff!
He's not crazy enough to do it!
I'll
bluff!
No one lives in that mansion anyway!
Just Alfred.
Just one guy.
The audio keeps cutting in and out.
Wait, is that true?
Or is it just your YouTube?
Is it just your YouTube?
Alright, we need the critical combo.
No, not Alfred.
Did you know in the comic series...
He's been dead for five years now?
Apparently.
Oh, it's just that guy?
Yeah, you got... I got one guy.
One guy!
I think you gotta check your PC.
Tell that one guy that you're dead.
I think you gotta check his PC.
One guy!
I think you gotta upgrade your PC.
Sir.
Oh, I can open doors.
Spoilers?
It's not a spoil...
Okay, you were never gonna read the fucking comic anyway.
You know how I learned about that?
From YouTube Shorts.
Alright, eventually the YouTube Short algorithms...
You'll find out.
Okay, you'll find out.
You don't know that.
Oh, yeah!
When was the last time you read a fucking Batman comic?
You do know people have not been reading comics in a long time.
The comic industry is fucking dying!
You... you are not gonna change!
You're the reason why the comic industry is dying.
I'm the reason why the comic industry is dying.
I literally am... I literally just watched...
Oh, people read the... read the... It's sad but it's true.
We all get our lore from fucking YouTube shorts!
Oh shit, is Poison Ivy gonna be here?
You're right, but still.
They booed her because she was right.
Oh, there's a garden in the asylum?
Oh no, this is outside.
Nevermind.
I was like... I thought I was still like inside for some reason.
I thought this was just a really big green house.
Okay, escape from intensive treatment to the island surface.
Nice.
Are those my guards?
Alright, two hostiles, two armed, zero unarmed.
No, these are my people.
Okay, these are not.
Not my...
Whoa!
Oh, it's okay.
I have the Batcave.
Nice.
It's me, Batman!
Can I scan a person?
No.
He doesn't matter apparently.
Okay, you guys said scan wing tech.
How the f...
Alert?
Batmobile sensor?
Where's my car?
Batmobile's countermeasure system.
I saw the alert.
What's wrong?
Where are you?
I'm outside the Arkham Mansion.
Harley Quinn probably triggered the alarm.
If she still got Gordon with her, he could get hurt.
Okay, done.
The Batmobile is still parked up outside the intensive treatment building in Arkham North.
I sent you the schematics for the entire island.
I've marked key locations...
Oh my god, there's a lot of things in front of me.
Thanks, Oracle.
This is a big map.
Protect the Batmobile.
Okay.
Medical facility...
Arkham Mansion.
Alright, people are saying I should scan the f... wing.
Let me scan it.
Let me scan it!
Wait, how do I zoom again?
Okay, there you go.
Come on.
You know you want to scan it.
Real soft.
Yay!
I didn't even have to read your riddle.
I have backseaters.
I can look at... I can look at...
I can look up about myself.
Okay.
Where's my bio?
Where is my billionaire bio?
Bruce Wayne.
Born into a wealthy Wayne family.
Bruce Wayne had an idyllic childhood.
Although he was given strong...
Have I... Has Bruce Wayne ever graduated university?
Does he even have a master's degree in business?
But his moralistic... moralistic and philatrap... philatrap... parents...
Thomas and Martha.
After their violent murder...
Um...
At crime alley...
Bruce dedicated his life...
He bought one tip...
Piling the cruel element that took their lives.
Yeah, it hasn't really helped much.
He left Gotham for many years to train his medical... mental and physical abilities across the globe.
Before finally returning to take up the mantle of the Dark Knight.
It doesn't say if he even has an education.
Why do you think...
Because he's running a fucking billionaire company.
I feel like...
I feel like you should have some sense of business sense.
You know?
I don't know.
Am I crazy to think that?
Is that too out of line to ask him to see if he has a business... a master's degree?
He signs papers.
I don't know.
Or...
Is he expecting too much?
He just signs the papers.
They give him the documents and then that is it.
Yeah, but don't you think he has to read the documents?
Guys.
Is that too much?
If he's gonna sign it, he has to read it too.
Right?
Like...
He has people to do that for him.
Oh shit.
Not the ambulance, guys.
Are you guys okay?
Not Jackson!
Guard Dump for Five?
Oh my god!
The dead guy has a name!
This is so fucked up.
No!
Jackson!
Oh shit!
Where's the gun?
Sorry, I didn't have my fucking detective mode on apparently.
Alright.
Let me get him on.
Alright, there you go.
Boop.
Goodbye!
And... you only have...
You get named when you die?
Apparently.
You have no importance until you're dead.
Oh shit.
Twiddle Dee and Tweedledum saw it.
Can you see it?
No!
Not my fucking car!
Fire Island will soon be under my control.
Jackson has been avenged.
Mine!
Bro, my car... I have no insurance!
There's a lot of cutbacks here.
I don't know how to get my car to work.
Hello.
Oh, they don't have guns!
Wait, they don't have guns.
This is good.
I guess I'll just beat them up.
It's okay guys!
No gun!
Oh shit!
Give me a sec.
Oh fuck!
Oh, I'm disoriented!
I'm disoriented right now!
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Just take his pipe.
Oh shit, nice.
Alright, punch him in the dick.
Alright, punch him in the head.
Easy.
Nice!
That was easy.
Oh my god!
Well...
Rest in peace, my car.
Collect explosive gel.
Can we use this to destroy structures?
Oh shit, nice!
I can finally destroy walls now!
Explosives may harm...
May.
Okay, but like, we don't care about that, right?
As long as it doesn't hurt me.
People eventually...
They were gonna die eventually.
I'm gonna die.
My insurance, no!
I need to search the area around the Batmobile.
There could be a clue as to where she took Gordon.
I just think I don't have insurance, cause why the fuck would you insure a Batmobile?
Cause like, what's the point?
Cause then, what's the point of having a secret identity?
If you try insuring a Batmobile?
What am I supposed to scan?
Watching you guys is like a night in.
Watching my favorite movie.
It's self-repairing!
Attack of the stupid bungling idiots!
Who can't find a job!
Wait, do I even have a license plate?
My god, I don't even have it licensed!
Okay.
Evidence scanner.
Alright, back seaters!
Stay in the orange.
Okay, but where the f- Where...
Am I supposed to scan?
Do I own an insurance company?
I just insured myself.
Oh.
Oh!
What is it?
Does he carry a pipe with him?
Gordon's favorite tobacco.
Gordon's smarter than he looks.
Left me a trail to follow.
Oracle, I found a pipe.
It has your father's initials carved on it.
It was a birthday gift I gave him last year.
Really?
No way he'd leave it.
Exactly.
He's left me a trail to follow.
He's alive, Barbara.
Look, it's...
It's a pipe.
I don't need to detect anything when I have these fists.
How do I destroy this?
Joker here!
What's that rule, Joker?
Following this rule is death.
It's a secret!
Do I not have the explosive gel already?
I do!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I can just do this.
Boop.
Oh, I detonate it.
Oh, that's just Batarang.
Okay, LT to prepare explosive gel.
They're not prepared it?
They're not prepared it enough?
Oh!
Okay.
I'm learning.
I drew the bat sign on it?
Batman, please.
Time and place.
It's gonna be blown up anyway.
Batman, please.
Who is this?
Who's looking at this?
It's just you and I.
Brand.
You don't get it, Doki.
It's branding.
Who's gonna look at the brand?
Tell me.
But the style...
Batman is a banksy.
To who?
Who is sending the...
Who is he sending that message to?
Where am I supposed to go?
Locate Gordon by... Oh, the track is...
Okay, there it is.
Come over and see me.
Don't look up when you open the door.
We are...
I'm going to have to find another way around to get back on track.
Wait, I want to know if there's anything up top.
So he knows who's gel it belongs to.
Yeah, but I want to know if there's anything here.
I need to go search for it.
What's this?
Ooh, Kate.
It says, Kate.
I'm sorry.
That's him.
The juggler.
Get my permanent record.
Be quiet, clone.
What the fuck is that other guy?
He claims a different type of psychosis.
I don't believe it.
He can have everything.
There are things you cannot cure.
Who the fuck hired this psych...
There is...
That is a fucking lie.
There are some mental disorders you cannot cure.
What are her credentials?
It's not fucking physical.
It's inner.
Oh my god.
Don't trust a psychiatrist that's like, anything can be cured.
You know what can't be fucking cured?
Can't... Oh wait, no.
Cancer can.
Depending on what type of cancer.
Nevermind.
Rabies!
Rabies can't be cured!
Doctor!
What about rabies?
Oh wait, let's see.
Banksy time.
Alright.
That's what I'm saying!
Don't trust a doctor that says anything can be cured.
That's just giving false hope.
Rabie... No it can't!
When you get rabies, you fucking die!
Oop.
It can kinda.
Alright.
If you say it can kinda.
That doesn't mean...
If it's caught in time.
Okay, if it's caught in time.
Yes.
But like, it doesn't mean it's curable all the time.
Alright.
Can I like unlock it from the outside?
Or inside?
Nothing.
Exactly!
That's what I mean!
That's why you don't trust any psychiatrist.
Or doctor.
That says anything can be cured.
That's just like...
Malpractice.
At that point.
Where are the enemies?
Eight host... Eight?
Oh shit, wait.
Whoa!
Can I head there now?
Ow.
Whoops, nope.
Trust no one.
Not even doctors.
Actually no, please trust your doctors.
Please don't do home remedies.
Oh.
Skin.
Wait, are these good guys?
Oh, they are definitely not good guys.
Don't worry.
They won't be able to see me when I walk very slow up to them, right?
Hello.
Yeah, he's too busy working.
He won't know either.
Wait, what are they building?
What is this?
Are they trying to improve the structural integrity of this building?
Then why am I silencing them?
Why?
They're just carpenters, Dokie.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
They're just trying to fix the structure.
I can't believe it.
We got a castle.
Cancel Batman.
Is he okay?
Are you okay?
Yeah, but I want to talk to this one guy.
Can't believe it.
Batman is against fucking handymen.
He's against trade schools.
What?
I want to talk to this one guy.
I want to see if he has a name.
Alright, I'll go inside.
What?
Me?
No.
Wait, go inside?
What's inside?
Hello?
Whoa.
I was thinking.
You really could use a friend in here.
Someone to talk to.
Share secrets.
He doesn't need friends.
That's why he adopts kids.
To fill that hole in his heart.
Who is that behind the mask?
Why do you feel the need to go out into the world and fight people like me?
Do you really think you could win?
Oh, I can move.
We'll see.
Wait,
this is first person now.
That's interesting.
Where do I go though?
Huh?
Can't do anything here.
Oh, is it only this building?
Is that it?
Do I leave?
Okay.
Joker?
Oh, you come back later.
Oh, it's an Easter egg.
Okay.
It's just to talk to Joker.
Oh!
I was gonna say.
Like.
What do I do next?
That's interesting.
That it's like first person.
Go back inside later?
Is it trying to turn into some fucking horror film?
Alright, where's the tobacco?
Oh, there it is.
There's six hostiles.
Six unarmed.
They don't have guns!
Time to beat them up.
They don't have guns.
This is perfect.
Wait, what's over there?
Oh shit, that's a lot of dead people.
Joker, you already said that again.
It wasn't funny the first time.
It wasn't cool!
Wait.
You know what?
I'm just gonna beat them up for XP.
Oh shit!
It's fine.
They don't have guns.
I ain't scared.
Oh shit, you have teeth!
Give me a sec.
Nice.
I love that money mashing.
Alright.
No!
Fuck!
Okay.
Oh shit.
No!
Alright, we're fine.
Big punch!
Oh!
Alright.
Brain damage!
It's fine.
I might get a little bit of brain damage too.
But I'm a streamer, so it's like part of the job.
Alright, nice.
Wait, where's the other one?
Where's the other teeth?
Oh my gosh, so hard to see the teeth.
You can't say thank you for the AKASUPA!
Thank you!
Potato.
That's me.
I swear to god, like...
Honestly, I feel like...
I should have like a...
A life to life...
A life to life exchange.
If they get to kill two people, I get to kill two people.
Cause like...
I'm pretty sure...
This is like ten families already.
Just in this general vicinity.
I have to like...
Pay for ten extra families.
Alright, open door.
Yay!
Harley!
Hey there.
Hey there, girl.
Where's Gordon?
Wouldn't you like to know?
I'm over here!
You crazy bitch!
Wait, where is he?
What's he doing?
It's too early!
I can fix her.
You'll be happy with me.
Best
day manager.
Oh, they're definitely...
They definitely like to have a voyeur too.
Oh yeah, they're freaky.
They're definitely freaky.
Yeah, it's Tara Strong.
Before she got super weird.
Okay.
One of the weirdest shit about her...
Is that like...
This is what's my gripe about...
Tara Strong.
Oh, it's not?
It's not her?
Oh shit, it's not?
Okay.
But anyway...
One of the weirdest shit about her...
Is that she was like...
No AI voices.
So because it hurts the voice acting industry.
And then later on she was like...
But AI art is okay.
I thought that was like pretty weird.
Not gonna lie.
I was like...
Alright, you can't pick and choose that.
I just thought that was fucking weird.
I feel like if you have a stats regarding a certain thing.
I feel like you shouldn't pick and choose.
Oh, that's Arlene?
I thought that was Tara's job because usually they get Tara for Harley Quinn.
Alright, let's see.
Search for a structural weakness in the exterior?
At this point, everything should be a structural weakness in this fucking city.
Alright, let's see.
But now 14 years ago?
Wasn't Tara Strong like the original voice actor- actress for Harley Quinn?
I thought she was when the original animated series.
Or was it...
Or was it Arlene?
Oh, Arlene was the original?
Oh!
Okay.
I didn't know that.
That's Arlene.
Why is Arlene not as popular?
Okay.
Batman.
Alright, dead meat.
Nice.
Oh, she's... she passed away.
Okay, that makes a lot more sense.
I didn't know that.
I think I like how Mark Hamill retired Joker when Kevin Conroy passed away.
Because that's very respectful.
I don't know why.
What?
Did I break this?
That's fucked up.
Being a doctor is very hard, Joker.
He spent like at least 10 years to get that degree, man.
We don't have enough people, Joker!
If we don't have doctors in Gotham City, then like, who the fuck is gonna patch you up?
There's not enough veterinarians for that!
Yeah... oh, this way.
Wait, how am I supposed to get the fucking trophy?
Where am I going?
He said...
He said Death Joker.
Oh, nice!
Trophy time.
Veterinarians?
Yeah, you don't know that?
I learned this from a movie.
But like...
Sometimes the mob use the veterinarians to patch them up.
Illegally.
So they don't have to go through a real doctor.
Obviously, movies are true.
Obviously!
What you see in the movies is what's actually going on.
Who's that guy?
Is that a doctor?
Yeah.
We do.
True.
Whoops.
Inverted takedown.
Woah!
Shit!
They don't see!
Woah!
Don't worry, I'm too fast.
I'm too fast.
Oh, wait.
I should not have done that actually.
Oh, hey.
He doesn't know.
Oh, that's a lot of people.
Oh, okay.
That is a lot of people.
Can I do more than one person?
Wait, where's the doctor?
What if I accidentally kill the doctor?
Can I?
Okay, this is science reasons.
Okay, no.
She's safe.
Alright.
I just wanted to know!
Because what if I accidentally kill her?
You know?
I'm just trying to make sure I don't accidentally kill anybody.
Alright.
I'm totally gonna get shot at when I do this.
Stealth mission.
I've been pretty stealthy like this, right?
Come on!
Get over here!
Wait.
Oh, there you go.
Yay!
Don't worry, I'll just fly.
Just keep flying.
He doesn't know.
Okay.
Come on!
After I kill the bat!
Yeah, after.
It's all about after.
Okay.
Maybe I...
What's going on?
Can I make them go over there?
Can I make them walk over there?
I can!
He's not gonna look up.
Trust me.
Come on!
Where are you?
Head down here.
You know you want to.
Come on!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
It's just two more steps?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute!
Okay, I can do it here.
I was gonna be like, that's...
I got lied to.
Okay.
Come over here.
You know you want to.
You know you wanna walk over there.
Come on!
Oh, fuck it.
I can't.
I'm not patient enough for this.
Fuck this.
His teammate's not gonna be helping him anyway.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Now he's not gonna...
Wait.
Is it...
Is he gonna shoot me?
No, he can't tell.
Is that the last guy?
Alright.
Wee!
Boom!
Get over here.
Nice!
I did it!
Doctors!
What is going on?
I did it, Doctors!
Looks like Harleen with the hair.
I don't know what happened.
Every red haired girl, Harleen.
Harley Quinn.
Harley is blonde?
Okay, I'm thinking about red hair, Harley.
I'm thinking about poison ivy hair.
I'm... okay, sorry.
I was watching Harley Quinn earlier.
And like, my hair colors got mixed up.
I was thinking about poison ivy.
I'm gonna say...
newest season of Harley Quinn...
pretty fucking shit.
The writing for that...
was god fucking weird.
Oh, interview tape.
Fake fa- Oh, I'm sorry, Mr. I didn't know Alfred died five years ago.
And was never brought back.
Then two legs.
And finally three legs.
Old man!
Yeah!
Oh, sorry, yeah, human, yeah.
Oh, wait, I'm so fucking smart.
Good try.
But the answer to all three is a baby.
What the fuck?
It's horrible.
How can you even joke about that?
Easily, doctor.
It's not my baby.
Whoa!
Geez, really?
That's fucked up.
Alright, let's see.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, I'm so close to leveling up.
Damn.
I mean, if you think about it, it works with old elderly too.
Oh, there's... oh, I can't...
I don't have the upgrade yet, right?
Oh, no, that's just a gargoyle.
I'm just gonna go to the other side.
It's the simple things.
Oh, shit, look at his packs though.
From that angle.
Alright.
Where am I supposed to go?
Locate and rescue Dr. Young.
Locate and rescue Dr. Kellerman.
Locate and rescue Dr. Chen.
Oh, it's Chen.
It's all the doctors.
Alright.
Does it really matter though?
Do we really need to rescue all these doctors?
Wouldn't Tool be enough?
Wouldn't Tool be enough, guys?
Uhh...
I'm so confused where to go.
Yeah, I don't like...
The only thing I don't like is when you go from detective mode... Oh, shit.
Nice.
When you go from detective mode to like...
uh...
to like normal mode, I do not like the flashes.
I can literally just hire more doctors outside of...
Oh, nice.
Outside of Gotham City.
I know earlier I was like, think of the doctors.
But now I'm like, wait, I can hire more.
Alright.
What do I upgrade?
Backseaters, it's time.
It's time to optimize my build.
Hahaha.
It's time.
It's optimization.
Armor?
Okay.
Vrooshit 1.
Alright.
Holy fuck.
Hahaha.
Oh my god, the fucking icon for that.
Why would they... Money!
It's always money.
Why?
You pay enough money, people will risk everything.
Where the fuck is the elevator?
Okay.
Alright.
How do I open that door?
Can I open doors?
Oh, I just press... Okay.
How do I open...
God, I'm so...
How do I open this door?
Alright.
Wait, how do we save this game?
Where's the checkpoint?
Oh my god, where's the checkpoint in this game?
Hahaha.
Warden!
Good afternoon, Arkham.
Let's talk about the mind.
How can such a complex entity be understood and eventually treated when it breaks?
How, indeed.
Project Titan's goal is to create a test bed to fully probe our special cases in a safe, risk-free manner.
Our goal is to cure more unfortunate specimens.
The weak.
Those not physically up to the challenge that our medical practices present.
Project Titan will make us a world-class facility.
An award-winning facility.
When you or someone you know is seriously distressed, there are few institutions where they can be taken, and where you can be reassured that they are safe and undergoing the finest care available.
An extensive breakdown of our costs and healthcare packages can be found at the front desk.
Is that a real site?
I had to be like 14 years ago.
... slash prices.
We accept most major HMOs.
Let me introduce you all to the sterling work of our new head of research...
Wait, let me open this door.
Is there an odd save when I open this door?
Let's try.
Does it tell me an icon?
Is that an... How do I know?
How do I...
How do I know if that auto saved me?
...
Okay.
Did that auto save?
It saved?
Alright.
Alright, we're gonna call it here because in an hour, we're gonna have another stream.
I'm sorry if I couldn't do a longer stream today.
It was a bonus.
This is a bonus stream.
But I had so much fun.
Um...
I'm gonna call it here so I can have a little bit of time in between streams.
Guys, but thank you everybody for coming!
This has been so much fun!
This has been so fun so far.
Uh...
But thank you everybody!
Thank you for all the super chats, for all the memberships!
I'll see you guys in an hour with Ditto and Uto.
Um... We're gonna be playing Apex Rank, uh... together.
We are the Apex Pred girl squad.
Um...
Um... Even though Uto is not Pred, she is Pred in my heart.
But yeah, as always everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get a bit more around to get that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, maybe stay up a little longer for some more... for some Apex.
Yeah, I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!